[Music]
the i-team learning new details in the
search for a missing henderson woman
jawahar hanji was last seen in this
surveillance video on your screen
walking along a trail
near a construction site in december she
hasn't been seen or heard from since
and several searches in the area have
come up empty-handed
now her family is talking to the i-team
about new clues
they hope gives investigators some
answers
i think somebody kidnapped her that's
what i believe i think something
happened to her because there's no way
there's no way at all that she wouldn't
contact us for this long
coming up new at six o'clock the i-team
takes a look at the case the new
information about what the 26-year-old
was doing
right before she disappeared and the
family continues to plead with
investigators to follow up on
any lead no matter how small you can
help by calling police or
crime stoppers using the phone number
right there on your screen both accept
anonymous tips as well as on their
website
lvmpd.com or crimestoppers of
envy.com